yeah someone's asking like you you can't
get rich by renting out your time is
there really any other way to get rich
yeah i mean if i had to summarize how to
make money at least from what i've
learned in life
you have to
you basically get rewarded by society
for giving it what it wants and it
doesn't know how to get elsewhere
and a lot of people think you can go to
school and you can study for
for how to make money
but the reality is there's no skill
called business
what you're actually trying to figure
out is what product or service does
society want but does not yet know how
to get and you want to become the person
who delivers that
and delivers it at scale
so that's really the the challenge and
how to make money and now the problem is
if society can't if you can't learn how
to do it then how do you become good at
it whatever it is and and what it is
moves around generation and generation
but a lot of it happens to be in
technology
uh and so it's a form of what i think
the austrians used to call austrian
economies it's called specific knowledge
knowledge that only you know or only a
small set of people know
and it's basically going to come out of
your passions and your hobbies oddly
enough so if you have hobbies around
intellectual curiosity you're more
likely to develop
these passions and you're more likely to
have skill sets that society does not
yet know how to train other people how
to do because if you can train other
people how to do something then it can
replace them and if you can replace them
they just have to pay them a lot so you
want to know how to do something that
other people don't know how to do at the
time period when they want it
so for example like you might be
interested in programming for computers
and you're into really esoteric deep
learning algorithms and it doesn't
really matter until society assembles
large enough data sets enough computing
machines that the gen the ai revolution
shows up and then all of a sudden your
hobby turns into specific knowledge
and then you want to take that specific
knowledge and you want to be known as
the person who can deliver that so you
have to have a brand and a reputation
and the most powerful brands and
reputations in the world
are
are individual brands like oprah trump
share you know like single names naval
you know to some extent i'm trying to
build a little bit of that brand
accidentally but if you have a unique
name if you can brand yourself in a
unique way and that branding doesn't
come for free that's account that has
accountability on the other side of it
so you're taking risks with brand you
get attacked you fail you can have
problems you're really sticking your
neck out there so you basically have to
have specific knowledge you have to take
on accountability with a brand and the
last piece of making money is you have
to have leverage
leverage is critical leverage you know
archimedes uh famously said um you know
give me a lever long enough and a place
to stand and i will move the earth
and uh that was a very powerful
statement when he was basically saying
it's the power of leverage and humans
are not evolved to understand leverage
our evolutionary past
maps inputs to outputs it's a one-to-one
ratio so for example uh if i'm chopping
trees and i'm like harvesting wood
to go start a fire
then
basically if i put in
you know eight hours chopping wood
that's probably gonna get me eight times
the output that i would get from
one hour of chopping wood
whereas with leverage uh you know i
might have bulldozers or chainsaws or i
might have lumberjacks working with me
and so if i make the right decision how
to cut down the wood how to store it how
to ship it and transport it i get a
multiplier effect and it's very
important to understand the different
kinds of leverage that are available
because if you want to make money you
need that specific knowledge you need
that accountability and now you're going
to need to use whichever form of
leverage best applies to your situation
and there are three broad classes of
leverage
one form of leverage uh is is going to
be
labor which is the oldest form of
leverage which is other humans working
for you
and that's actually not a great one in
the modern world it used to be great in
the old world but in the modern world
people are on to it so everyone's always
playing a status game and trying to
become the lead monkey in the tribe uh
and so i said so having people work for
you is a difficult form of leverage
then there's capital which is a more
recent invention it's only about you
know a few thousand years ago goes back
to the agricultural age and so that's
money and so if you have money as a form
of leverage that's a good one it means
like every time you make a decision now
you multiply this with money and that's
why fund managers and venture
capitalists and so on seem to do well
and then the final form of leverage is a
brand new form of leverage and that's
like the most democratizing one
and that is a products that have no
marginal cost of replication
so that would include books it would
include media it would include movies it
would include code
and code is probably the most powerful
form of leverage that is permissionless
all you need is a computer you don't
need anyone's permission so if you want
to make the maximum amount of money
possible like if you just if you just
want to get rich over your life and you
want to do it in a deterministic
predictable way what you would do is you
would basically stay on the bleeding
edge of trends and you would study
technology and just design and art and
things that you think
and you would become really good at
something you would basically be waiting
for your moment until something emerged
in the world where they needed that
skill set
and you're uniquely qualified you would
build your brand in the meantime on
twitter on youtube by giving away free
work so people have heard of you you
would make a name for yourself and you
would take some risks in the process
and then when it was time to move in on
that opportunity you would do so with
leverage the maximum leverage possible
and the maximum leverage would mean that
you would have people working for you it
would mean you had a fund or you would
have capital it would mean that you
would be writing a book it would mean
that you'd be writing code and that
you're building a media presence
basically what i'm doing i'm kind of
doing it more by accident i actually
don't really care that much honestly i'm
more of an intellectual
i learned how to make money because it
was a necessity
after it stopped being a necessity i
stopped caring about it uh every time uh
you know i look at some of my colleagues
in silicon valley who are working really
really hard and have made lots of money
but they continue working hard
and i see them like then donating like
hospital wings and you know i just think
oh that person overshot like they just
you know at some point it would have
been logical to stop or if unless they
really enjoyed it um in which case you
know god bless you do whatever you want
but at least for me
work was a means to an end
and
you know making money was a means to an
end
but fundamentally
you know
i'm much more interested in solving
problems
than i am in making money
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you